der mann hat ein gerüttelt maß an
selbstbewusstsein motrip sagt von sich
selbst ich bin besser als ich tue jetzt
im fragen lotto und wir diskutieren
darüber ob er ein ausnahme rapper oder
ein ausnahme schreiber ist also bitte
kommentiert hat er zu viel oder zu wenig
selbstbewusstsein bis dahin da dran
ok also willkommen zum höhepunkt des
heutigen abends oder tages fixpunkt bei
euch ja fragen wir doch gut ja also wir
haben uns wieder bemüht ganz gemeinden
ganz harmlose frage zu finden greift
sowie sonne gab es auch alle nehmen so
wie du bist vielleicht mal gemeint dass
die meisten nehmen weil ich alle ist uns
alle
so
fühlst du dich mit deinen
anspruchsvollen texten ist in der
hip-hop-szene fehl am platz das ehrt
mich gleichermaßen wie es mich
beleidigt deswegen swiss open 2010
werden je nach hellmers gefragt hat da
draußen fragt er
also in ihm haben zusammen überlegen was
man sich den gemeinden fragen aber das
ist ja irgendwie ziemlich grüne gute
frage aber das ist ja voll als
kompliment einerseits ist das kompliment
aber es könnte auch eine beleidigung
sein in der ich hab ja eigentlich vorher
überlegen was man für dexter machten ein
bisschen krasser könnten eher seiten
also böse also
wenn er
hat sich ja das kann auch dieses spiel
dafür gibt's ja ja wahnsinn was er macht
und dafür gibt es halt auch nicht für
die das ist halt nicht wollen die dann
die anspruchsvollen texte wollen aber
ich finde sportlich fehl am platz wir
decken mittlerweile einfach alle
facetten habe ein haftbefehl hat seine
berechtigung wie ist sie habe und das
ist hip hop szene benutzt du lernen
willst wir sind einfach wir machen die
musik und wenn was da einzuordnen ist
ich will irgendwann dass man sagt das
wünsche ich mir irgendwann sagt man
bestimmt das ist kein hip hop musik der
markt und deswegen also ich bin froh bin
ich darüber
hinaus gewachsen da nicht mal grün und
ab jetzt ein zubringer die sind noch
visa visa weil
im rücken hat sich doch was ist bewusst
so zum ausnahmeläufer geworden versteht
also man man man muss sich selber ja
auch in meinem himmel loben genau das
ist das problem ich sehe mich nicht als
ausnahme rapper warum nicht sage ich
ganz offen ja und jetzt werde ich gerade
mental verwenden so oft weil gesagt
haben steht noch mal zu dir ich stehe ja
rapper mit grips im text bei dir drin
schon also ich bin ausnahme schreiber ok
definitiv ich könnte ihn für jede
musikrichtung mittlerweile habe ich das
gefühl schreiben habe ich auch schon
nicht nur hip hop geschrieben und warum
ist der ausnahme rapper wenn wir denn
jetzt redet
wegen den texten glaube ist weil rappen
kann viele stimmen sind verschieden
gemacht werden verschiedenste stimmen
daran wird es liegen ist wird an meinen
texten die wiederum dass wir wieder bei
punkt eins aber der roten frage also ich
bin zum aufnahmeleiter geworden weil ich
die besten texte in der letzten zeit
abgeliefert haben ok
wieder rot rot rot rot rot so
machst du es dir nicht zu leicht mit
seinem trip theorie baukastenprinzip
den song heißt
nein mache ich nicht finde ich mache es
den anderen leicht ein wenig ihnen das
weiter gebe die theorie wurde mir auf
mysteriöse art und weise übermittelt wie
wurde die über mietet findest du mal
dass uns die leute raus sind meine
stimme plus die technik meine floss
geteilt des skills ist gleich der
inbegriff von fashionistas noch -
also sprich willst du so sein wie tritt
muss einfach deine stimme unter
kontrolle kriegen auf technik 18 coole
beats floss dann muss noch wagners ganz
ausschalten du darfst nicht reden weil
spox gegen berlin geholt ist dann sagt
es auch um sein
- take that noch also sei echt lang
diskutiert und dann kann es auch ganz
auch der ausnahmen sind eigentlich schon
gefallen damit ihr leben das leben sagt
oder weiter ganz okay okay ist beitragen
schreibt seit zehn jahren text
bauhausstadt über die alpen herrschen
gute frage darauf bin ich dafür müssen
ein gegangen ich war nicht zufrieden ich
schreib tatsächlich schon sehr lange
texte hat er schon oft phasenweise das
gefühl cool mixtape ist bald fertig und
hey wenn ich werde dein album ist fertig
gott sei dank habe ich nicht gemacht ich
bin froh dass das jetzt mein erster
schritt nach außen ist richtig aber
eigentlich nur weil ich so
selbstkritisch bin weil ich nicht mit
mir zufrieden war und ja das ist ein
grund hat sicherlich ein punkt dass dein
vater immer gesagt wenn man das einmal
gemacht sondern die stimmt aber also
mein vater verdienen gibt es ja keinen
unterschied da macht er musik also
verschwendet keine zeit oder macht der
musik und bringt irgendwann noch ein
internet album all das geht ja gar nicht
okay war dass er macht musik das war
schon ein problem und für mich war das
so ich will raus mit sachen entstehen
kann ja ich kriege immer wieder mal
jetzt wird der song damals war schon gut
das ist unfassbar schlecht dann haben
wir sorgen ist weiß nicht was die leute
meinen und ich bin froh dass ich nicht
ein album wo es heute nicht mehr unter
stress macht und ich glaube ist ein
embryo werde ich wie immer stehen ok
also für dich ist nicht ist es
wahnsinnig wichtig dass die leute sich
nicht nur feiern sondern dass ich nicht
feiert auf seinem grund den du kennst
und nicht so nach dem motto ich weiß
jetzt auch nicht was den gefangenen ist
aber die finden denn gut wäre ja auch
komisch sein kann und dann kann ich
meine theorie auch nicht mehr so lange
dann habe ich ein zufallsprodukt so
gemacht das will ich gar nicht sein dass
steht also das habe ich noch nie so
darüber nachgedacht ob du hast du
scheinst recht sagen ich weiß schon dass
man weiß was ich kann oder was ich mache
und dass man mich dafür feiert und nicht
dass man immer das kommt wahrscheinlich
daher dass man mich früher schnell mit
bushido oder co sage ich mal vergessen
also weiß für bushido niko gibt er war
ja einzigartig dann in dem den auch aber
dann wirst du damit verglichen du siehst
du aus und ich musste mich immer schon
davon abgrenzen es ist mein und das ist
das prägt und auf jeden fall dann willst
du zeigen ist mal was ganz anderes
vorbild dafür ich bin nicht sehen nicht
nur cool aus ist kann auch was okay das
war mir ganz wichtig wer war ich deine
maßstab dann warum machen wir das gute
war mal was du selber der konnte das
entscheiden das ist nicht gut genug also
meine jungs haben leider immer alles
abgesehen gemeint da fällt drauf damit
alter fällt aber ich bin der mann stark
nebenbei habe ich mir natürlich das
sagen das ist nicht mein bruder gesagt
wer stone glaubt mir der ist krass dann
finde ich ihn auch irgendwie klasse hat
gehen aber eigentlich bin ich selber
mein anspruch was ist das beste an dir
ohne wird es meine bescheidenheit so
weil ich finde ich bin besser also tun
aber das mache ich nicht bewusst ist so
also ich sag nur sagen wir formulieren
ist sodann ist es wahr andere wurden mit
viel weniger vielmehr protzen das weiß
ich einfach ich weiß was ich weiß wie
mein leben aussieht ist weiß womit ich
alles angeben können sie momentan aber
warum das ist nicht meine natur gewesen
und nur weil ich ein rapper bligg nicht
liebe zeigen alle da ihre zweifel das
rennauto angeht was hast du genau genau
1 momentan kann es schaffen ekelhaften
subaru ich habe tatsächlich hat ein
super in dem video ich hatte auch
ausreichend gutes auto wenn sich
zumindest nah dran ist er okay wir haben
natürlich ein bisschen präpariert aber
es wäre aber das ist ja der wagen ich
hatte auch mal corsa aber also statt
demolierten wagen ich habe oft bleiben
ich fahre gern fette wagen und momentan
bin ich mir dass der luxus oft dass ich
mir so viel zug fahren sondern
irgendwann wagen nehme aber ich sag dir
das beste an mir ist dass ich
einfach bescheiden an die sache rangehen
mir einfach das nicht so genannten zu
kaufen ist hier zu kopf steigen erst
immer wieder sei es also versucht da
immer bodenhaltung nachts rein ja ich
mache erst mal
und sind echt fiese ist noch wohin er
dann immer gedacht die grünen nicht aber
die sind halt dankbar für diese denn die
bühne direkt bei einer großen
plattenfirma musikern wie hast du denn
das geschäft die school ja um ganz offen
zu sein also ich hab ja videos gemacht
dann habe ich zu cover my song geschafft
und ich glaube dass der coversong abend
das wird bei vox ausgestrahlt ganz viele
leute vom überzeugt hat auf einen schlag
weil die gesehen haben krass kommen was
der dafür texte schreibt innerhalb von
48 stunden und
dann kam auch university unter anderem
halt und spannend natürlich unheimlich
spannend mit wohnungen major label mal
zu reden und auch der ennahda wenig
bekommen habe hat mich sehr interessiert
also ich wollte schon sehr gern schöne
bürsten und deswegen
dna wie halt macht ist artist and warte
man das ist sogar der für den links
verantwortung für den künstler der ddr
kauft die könig wo ich auch machen aber
es gelingt mir geraten hat es den rapper
tragen glaub ich habe seines wissens
jahr seien nach es ist kein plan aber
das sagt etwas cool einer großen
plattenfirma ich mache musik machen das
also ich könnte zwar trotzdem wissen was
es heißt aber ich muss mich echt und
nichts davon ich mache mich die krone
ich mache nichts ich mache meine musik
wir haben nicht geholt und mir gesagt
sei du so mach dein ding und das mache
ich zu unserem deswegen habe ich auch
geschafft weil ich im moment liegen auch
wirklich ich bin ich geblieben das hat
man bei vox gesehen und das haben dann
auch die plattenfirmen sind super und
das man ja
dass die sagen ja hallo das ist
verbiegen ich hab mein album einfach
abgegeben oder handy video dazu genug
leben um aufs blatt zu kritzeln reicht
das
neuerdings habe ich das gefühl das ist
ganz in meiner zukunft vielleicht ich
habe ganz lange gedacht das wird nicht
reichen mein vater sagt er im selben
song also ich ja dass wir diesen hier
nach zehn jahren könnte so zumindest ein
paar kleine scheine machen das war lange
meine befürchtung dass ich nicht das ist
nicht reicht und momentan kann ich das
nicht sagen ey geht so gut ich habe
viermal aus gesorgt so aber ich habe
jetzt das gefühl die leute geben eine
chance mich zu beweisen wenn ich jetzt
ein krasses album abgeben krasses
zweites album abgebe dann wird das
reichen aus blatt zu kürzen um zu leben
super das freut nicht dann hoffe ich
dass sorgen von parma treffen sehr gerne
sagen dass uns eingeladen hast ja gerne
ist guckt ja immer vorher fleißig und
ich komme gerne wieder sehr gut
das war alles gute und wenn er jetzt
noch sehen wollt wie einer beim fragen
lauter so richtig ausflippen dann guckt
euch das mit dj und auch ein sehr
lustiges fragen auto das mit haftbefehl
wo ich ihn unter anderem frage wann er
endlich gute musik macht und auch nicht
zu vergessen natürlich wenn er hier
motorrad gesehen hatte in rot mit motrip
unterwegs in aachen und pasan frisur da
passiert eine menge lustiges bis dann
bleibt